mark is in Maryland mark how are ya good
a you don't they do better than I
deserve what's up said about a year ago
me and my wife we call them we did our
debt free screen paid off a hundred
thousand and fourteen months since then
we we're moving on to baby step four
five and six look at you man and and
we're expecting our second child it's
due October 11 alright so what we've
done is we've put everything on hold
like we and sit just stacking up money
just just like you say and within that
time frame and it's crazy like I say you
take care of the little things and the
big things you get more responsibility
with and that's exactly what's happened
with us so within the last 12 months
like my businesses has taken a lot even
more so we've saved personal about
hundred thousand and then I've never had
retained earnings or anything like that
I've got thirty five thousand or teen
your earnings wow look at you
well you're over saving yeah yeah you
already got your baby step two three in
place you are debt-free except the house
you have your emergency fund right yeah
okay I don't I don't tell you to stop
everything for baby in there the only
time we tell you to stop everything is
when you're broke and then baby step two
okay okay deal no big deal you're just a
hundred thousand bucks ahead it's not a
problem okay so like so we could like we
have thirty thousand at our emergency
phone so we could essentially just get
down to that yeah everything down to
that and it ought to be invested or
throw really thrown at the house exactly
where you are or if you want hey if you
want to hold back I mean you can hold
back
twenty grand of it and put ten thousand
and five twenty nine this year ten
thousand 529 next year for new baby if
you wanted to I don't care yeah because
in my mint with my CPA again last like
two or three weeks ago and they were
suggesting that I put twenty five
thousand into like a step and then that
will save me four thousand all my tax
bill not if it's not 15 percent of your
income it
it should be over 15% and hey let's
review I mean where does it stop
stopping let's review baby step 3 is
your debt free and you have an emergency
fund in place
okay you're there then baby step 4 is 15
percent of your income not 13 percent
not 28 percent 15 percent of your income
going into retirement once you're doing
that the spillover of your fabulous
income goes to but it goes to baby step
5 which is kids college and you address
kids college however you want to address
it you can throw some lump sums at it
like I'm talking about or whatever okay
then once you're addressing college and
baby step 5 everything else goes to pay
off your house yes okay okay I got you
so you're saying not if like don't put
the twenty five thousand and we have
already put in fifteen percent of our
income correctamundo
okay okay throw that money go ahead and
that you'll do that in other years but
right now we're gonna get the house paid
off with that money
oh yeah go on I was looking at it the
other day we 2 to 15 I think
at daum man what do you imagine what's
your household income so we're still
kinda out the numbers but I mean we
should bring in like 240 I want to say
this here you say you're gonna pay it
with a hundred thousand bucks we just
found cuz you got 30 plus 100 don't you
yeah I've got and I mean that's another
thing like you know with that money all
I'm gonna do there is just throw it at
the house so we just put a hundred
thousand bucks on the house and you run
off the house like next year at your
rate maybe the year after I mean you're
having no mortgage then you load up
everything you max out sets your max out
Roth's your max out whatever 401ks and
you load the kids college funds and then
you just go off into the sunset being
outlandishly outrageously generous and
you have a lot of fun with money and
that's really all that's good for your
man you are so close to completely
breaking through baby step 7 you just
got a doll in these last few steps again
just reset dial back in dial back in
you're very very close
don't let your CPA get you distracted
you were almost
the finish line and congrats on the new
baby dude that's awesome